30 year old andrew heeney
who's coming off a very good start
against the giants but otherwise his
numbers aren't overly impressive with a
4.76 era now the royals need to get him
the earlier the better you know they've
been out to be careful with him though
he's got very deceptive delivery
ball gets on you in a hurry and the
pitch this is grounded sharply but right
at short gobbled up by iglesias his
throw to goslin in plenty of time
easy play two are gone and salvador
perez the catcher for the royals will be
the next batter
next pitch and this is lifted high in
the air it's hit pretty deep out into
right center field out on the warning
track making the grab on that one is
taylor ward almost the same spot as the
bald and mirrorfield hit to lead off the
inning so three up and three down not
many pitches in the inning just a total
of seven for andrew haney youngster
chris hubich
years old out of stanford and he has
appeared in eight games for the starter
he's done a very fine job in the
opportunities he's gotten so far from
kansas city angels have a base runner
and shohei ohtani
who is the only left-handed hitter in
this
game tonight will get ready to bet 2-2
he lifts this ball high and he hits it
deep out into right center field it is
way out of here
tuesday night bottom of the first inning
it's already show time
and this one is also a change-up and
this is right down the middle of the
plate
470 4-7-0
that was clobbered and here it comes a
swing and a miss and they finally get
the first out of the first inning on a
strikeout of max dassey the o2
struck him out with a curveball
so he gets the second out but it comes
on the 40th pitch the 1-0 pitch is lined
sharply but caught by gutierrez for the
final out
the angels get two on the home run by
shohei ohtani
and
chris bubich has to throw more than 40
pitches in the first inning to get three
outs angels have a two-nothing lead
we're in the second inning runner
at second also one at first here's a
ball chopped to fletcher touches the bag
at second fires the first base and they
turn a double play
so just like that two are gone dozier
moves over to third he's there with two
outs though and the next batter will be
the center fielder michael a taylor one
two pitch he got him swinging chased a
high fastball 94 miles per hour first
strikeout of the night for hiney comes
at a good time and they leave that
runner at third base justin upton will
be the next batter the 2-0 is swung on
and hit
left center field taylor coming on dives
and makes a terrific catch what a play
by michael taylor that's hit well
left center taylor dives and he's got it
with a backhand and then tumbles to his
feet excellent job he committed he
rolled nicely
hey otani leads off the bottom of the
third angels lead the game two nothing
here's the next pitch he drills that one
and it's going to take a couple of
bounces and
be stopped out on the warning track by
dozier and ohtani will just cruise in a
second and he is there with a stand-up
double
and a change-up fooled him so no 3-2
count this time around and bubic
strikes out his third one away and max
stassi will be the next hitter here's
the next pitch he swings at that one and
lifts that ball high and he hits it deep
out to left field it is out of here
second night in a row max stassi is
homered angels have now had a pair of
two run homers in the early going and
the lead grows it's four nothing in the
pitch
and a ground ball up the third base line
deep behind the back gutierrez has it
long throw gets him at first base long
throw by gutierrez what a play jose
iglesias will lead off the angels bottom
of the fourth and the next delivery this
is lifted high in the air this ball is
going to get out as well iglesias has
hit one out out to the bullpen area
angels are playing home run derby
tonight it's five nothing
justin upton will be the next batter
this is it hard and deep to the gap of
left center field up the loads up davis
was not coming back well upton's been
hitting a lot of home runs lately and he
hits one here
angel's lead just keeps on growing it's
now six nothing
in the pitch and a wave and a miss and a
strikeout
of shohei ohtani on a pitch down and in
so chris bubba strikes out his fourth
michael lay taylor will be the next
batter he went down swinging his first
time up one-two pitch and there's a
swing and a miss high fastball the
taylor goes after and boy that match up
there was no contest another strikeout
for
hiney who's actually struck out three of
the last four going back to last inning
so runners at second and third and it's
on its way he got him swinging struck
him out and that's how the ending will
end they leave a pair of runners on at
second
and third
so the first batter for the angels will
be anthony rendon here's the one-two
pitch and brendon swings and misses at
the slider and strikes out count two and
two to stassi who is one for two with
the two run home run back in the third
that off bovich who gave up four home
runs tonight he had only given up two
the entire season probably two prior to
this evening and there's a 98 mile an
hour heater right on the black outside
corner stassi doesn't agree
and hangs around home plate but that was
a beautiful pitch thrown by ronald
velanos who has struck out the first two
angels he's faced here in the fifth
inning the 3-2 pitch got him struck him
out swinging 96 mile an hour fastball
boring in on the right-handed batter
three up three down he is not allowed to
run in this game he's working in inning
number seven runner first two down the
pitch swing and a liner down the left
field line that's a hit he's gonna go
all the way to the corner michael taylor
can fly
he'll be waved around third base he'll
come in and score on an rbi double to
left field by hanzo alberto and the
royals are on the board it is six to one
andrew haney great job his night's
coming to an end so he goes six and two
thirds bases are loaded here salvador
perez at the plate
delivers jammed him broke his bat it's
now the like ball stopped by gosling
he'll beat him to the bag and the inning
is over here's taylor ward he's been a
strikeout victim
two of the three times he's batted he's
over three here's the pitch this is hit
well into left center field it's
traveling deep and it is out of here
taylor ward has just hit the fifth home
run of the night for the angels in this
game and the angels lead grows it's now
eight to one
hunter alberto
left side brandon
clutch
and that'll do it